معاناه كبيره للايرانيين جعلت من شراء
القوت اليومي امرا شاقا وامام ذلك لا يصرف
النظام موارده على تخفيف من المعاناه بل
على زياده وتطوير وسائل القمع في يناير
الماضي وافق المشرعون الايرانيون على
الخطوط العريضه لمشروع قانون الميزانيه
للسنه التي تبدا في الحادي والعشرين من
مارس المقبل الانفاق كان للجهات التي كانت
ناشطه في التعامل مع التظاهرات زيادات
كبيره مقارنه بالعام الماضي وزاره
الاستخبارات ازدادت ثلاثه واربعين في
المئه الشرطه اكثر من 44% لجنه الامر
بالمعروف والنهي عن المنكر 33% الحرس
الثوري هو الاخر زاد طبعا لنسبه 37% كل
هذا معلن لكن السري اظهرته وثيقه نشرتها
ايران انترناشونال الحرس الثوري طالب
الحكومه بعدم اعلان ميزانيه شرطه الاخلاق
من اجل منع الت نشرها سيضحض فكره اعلان
حلها كل هذا يصرف بينما تضمنت الميزانيه
زياده رواتب موظفي الحكومه بنسبه 20%
زياده نعم لكن ظاهريه فقط هي في الواقع
تخفيض الاسعار زادت اكثر من الرواتب نسب
التضخم ارتفعت مستويات قياسيه وصلت الشهر
الجاري الى اكثر من
53% وبالتالي القوه الشرائيه انخفضت لكن
في هذه الاثناء هناك من يرى ذلك عدلا راس
الدوله
مهماريس
العدو الذي يتحدث عنه الرئيس الايراني لا
تعكسه ارقام الميزانيه ستجعل الناس اكثر
فقرا بحسب خبير في منظمه الخطه والميزانيه
الايرانيه وبالتالي انفجر الايرانيون في
الشوارع مره اخرى بعد فتره من الهدنه
[موسيقى]